mike i think i told you on on friday i
think it was friday i told you
this uh this project one of the projects
i'm working on right now
has led me back uh through nfl history
uh specifically sometime part of it with
the cleveland browns
and and as part of it i found myself
over the weekend
watching a couple of i guess
iconic games in nfl history dubious
infamous games in cleveland brown's
history one of them
was the drive john elway gets the ball
at his own two he's down 20-13 about
five minutes to go in the fourth quarter
afc championship game
goes down the field ties the game they
win in overtime cleveland
no super bowl next year uh
cleveland goes down john elway and the
broncos again this time in denver it
goes down 28-10 come back
tie the score now they're down seven
ernest beiner about to tie the score
running into the endzone fumble no super
bowl
and then after that mike uh the browns
were taken out of cleveland by art model
and taken from cleveland to baltimore uh
that
that that thus we get the baltimore
ravens
the baltimore ravens are born and the
browns
also are the uh the one team that can
say
uh we fired both paul brown and bill
belichick
i mean amazing uh that is the definition
of dubious distinction
i mean yeah so when you look at the
cleveland browns that's why i say
you'd root for the browns too just
really new
not only their history because a lot of
teams have a history
that they're not proud of but if you
just
knew how much these people
want to win it is a cleveland ohio
is a brownstown i know lebron won in
2016.
uh i know the indians have been to the
world series it's been close to win the
world series
it is not a baseball town it is not a
basketball town
hockey didn't make it there it is a
cleveland
it's like a little football it is the
crazy football
right that is it everywhere you know
paul brown was a high school coach
uh before and a college coach in the
state of ohio
i mean you know that there are the the
pro football hall of fame where they
have a hall of fame game
that is a high school stadium more than
twenty thousand
as players know yes unfortunately it is
that's a high school system
yeah i really want to see
i say all that to say this i really want
to see the cleveland browns i want to
see them make the playoffs they haven't
made the playoffs in 18 years
i want to see them win a playoff game
uh they haven't won a playoff game uh
since bill belichick was their coach
yeah in new year's day 1995.
so this is an organization that
you could root for i didn't root for
them growing up but yeah
but just looking back on their story and
all the things that they've been through
the browns browns fans through all of
this
one thing they haven't been is
they ain't fair weather oh they they're
not there oh oh they're there they're in
they're in the browns fans will fight
you they'll fight you physically they'll
fight you
absolutely they'll fight each other also
they'll fight one they'll fight one
another they'll be a video earlier
fight one another in the stands yeah
they'll fight one another yeah they will
fight for what they believe is theirs
because you know why they're uh
you know why they're called the
cleveland browns
or paul brown art art model took the
team to baltimore you know why it wasn't
the baltimore browns which was which was
rumored oh no they kept them because
they were keeping their history
they were keeping fighting they fought
they went to court
yeah said no you're not taking our net
you can't have our name
you can't have our colors you can't have
our history let's go
i want to see the stephen browns who are
a good team
they're a good team yeah now this is not
a flukey thing
now okay let's just get there let's get
there
that's where i want to go all right
thank you for the history lesson but
let's talk about the president
so after the offseason he had and
everybody was like this is the year
they got the brakes beat off right in
the opener against the ravens all right
then they won four straight now remember
they weren't four straight we were like
okay browns might be for real because
they beat the colts for that four
straight away like okay the bronze might
be something
then the steelers beat them 38-7
not 7-7 38-7
still and i remember saying but i
remember saying on this show at the time
i remember saying to you don't ask we're
not talking about the bronze
don't don't ask about the browns i'm not
giving him the time of day
i'm not falling for this here but then
in the tailpipe again i was like
i'm not talking about these frauds they
always
think they on the cusp of something only
they give beat 38 to 7 when it matters
all right everybody they come back and
reel and they're winning i'm getting
there
and they come back and they're winning
and yesterday for me was different
i will admit it yesterday got my
attention yesterday got my attention in
the way that this team
had not all season because they were one
one in three
against teams of winning records
entering yesterday i believe
and they got baltimore coming to town
this week but yesterday doing what they
did against tennessee
and especially how baker mayfield in
that passing game kevin stefanski's
passing game
exploited the weakness that is
tennessee's past defense and lack of
pass rush
i was impressed i was impressed enough
to be like you know what
good for them good for them they got the
second longest playoff draw to your
point in the nfl behind the bills who
are also going to the playoffs
20 20 in a nutshell bills and browns in
the playoffs when they usually meet at
the end of the year for nothing
um but no i was i was i was
wholly impressed by baker mayfield's
performance and baker has
been a guy that i haven't really warmed
up up to i have liked his press
conferences
how he you know why haven't you made it
up to him
well just as a as a player i just i'm
not even talking personally like what
whatever no i'm not like
a player no i mean i just i you know
i i haven't seen number one overall pick
out of him not consistently
you know and and game manager is an
unfortunate uh
slur when it comes to football
conversations when
the very nature of the quarterback
position is to manage the game
so i reject the idea that a game manager
is a bad thing but you don't draft the
game manager number one overall
but i mean yesterday he let that thing
fly hey thanks for watching brother from
another on youtube
make sure you hit subscribe before you
leave and be sure to watch us
3 to 5 p.m eastern time on peacock
appreciate you